As you can see, there are many different
types of resources available to you.
So it's important to have a way of
determining whether a particular
resource should be used.
Here are three things you want to
consider before deciding to rely on
a resource for help.
One, is it up to date, software
versions are constantly changing.
Two, is it accurate, or in other words,
is the person providing the information
knowledgeable enough to trust.
Three, is it relevant?
This one can be difficult, especially
when you're just starting out.
The resources you find may not exactly
match up with what you're trying to do.
In that case, you may need to do more
research to verify that it can be used
to solve your problem.